happy turkey day yes right out of the
gate what what's going on the plane
Boyle bingo Thanksgiving edition
everyone filled out their cards with
possible Charles related scenarios first
to bingo gets a hundred bucks
I had Boyle calls at turkey day in the
center square Boyle explains that they
lobsters the first Thanksgiving they did
back in that time they called lobsters
ocean bugs and I'll just mark off for
you I think I got the winning card here
Boyle tells us that he played Pocahontas
in his third grade play all the girls
were too big this is a fun one Boyle
says gobble gobble gobble well now that
I know you want me to say that I'll just
say it with two levels gobble yeah it
just it just sounds right that way Wow I
don't like this game Mac well objective
Boyle bingo
come on guys Boyle says come on guys
that's to fatigue well guess what I can
spoil your little game by sitting over
here quietly all day and doing nothing
Oh anybody have Boyle falls on the floor
no one that's a victory that's a victory
for Boyle boom boy this is listen I
forgot to tell you the plan for the
Saturday you me bar beers buzzed wings
shots drunk waitresses packed football
Cornell Hofstra slaughter then quick nap
at my place and we hit the kids Alan no
I don't want to do any of that
uh-huh which is why I was joking about
doing it just stop stop just stop doing
it you're going to drive me crazy finals
go sit at my desk and be quiet sorry I
annoyed you with my friendship
[Music]
excuse me and I'm also sorry that a lot
of people here for some reason think
it's funny to steal someone's personal
property and hide it from them here's a
little news flash
it's not funny in fact it's pretty
frickin unfunny
hey there Boyle how was your weekend
well actually I got a little sick oh
really
I'm sorry to hear that man yeah bullets
over Broadway was on TV I came down with
a big old Dianne Wiest infection
like why is my girlfriend here Oh is she
that teacher in the white no she's a
part-time frozen yogurt chef which one
is she the one in the green hoodie Wow
she's like a guidance counselor so no
falling so it's a probably a tutor no
she's probably now oh and you know what
we don't have a lot of time so we should
probably J Mandy Oh what are you doing
here Andy are you a student here oh yeah
you never told me you were in high
school this is weird
I gotta go to Spanish oh my god oh my
god I had no idea well that's not gonna
hold up in court we didn't do anything
illegal except knock over in mailbox
with our friends the issue with the
watermark is very serious absolutely we
teach our students that character counts
should you don't teach it well enough
when your students is a yeah chandi is
having a real rough day today I want to
take out an ad in your yearbook
full-page two words good luck
that's not what I had in mind dates on
open cases I just got a deal and
Bessemer Street you're the primary
you're in charge
take Diaz and Peralta yes my fantasy
threesome of cops on a case Andy
but in the tale of Sweeney Todd pistons
pale and his I was odd
yes he the faces are gentle men never
thereafter were her up again baton at a
few had rod it's weed
Todd the Demon Barber of Fleet Street
right now ok supersonic who is he
swing door
[Music]
we're the cast of Sweeney Todd the Demon
Barber of Fleet Street we open in a
couple of weeks at the loose crew
Playhouse here in Scranton and today
just doing a wee bit of oil market it's
about me saving Christmas stuff David
snacks now you have to wait for backup
no I don't I'm gonna shim them off how
the eye contact is the worst part I told
you Jake
I'll do anything to perk up my little
man you've gotta know how gross that
sounds in your underwear
let's see la you know your big read
history bring it who is Cornell's 8th
president Dale Raymond Corson I'm sorry
that's incorrect Cornell's 7th president
was in fact James 8th Perkins
comprehension skills up our interviewing
skills subpar what are you writing can't
even you give Cornell your full
attention on the contrary I'm helping
Cornell by evaluating their interviewers
nobody wants that to happen well when
they get my evaluation we'll see if
they're interested applicant is
attempting to blackmail
interviewer showing low moral character
interviewer is threatening applicant
with an arbitrary review process
applicant is wasting everyone's time
with stupid and inane accusations
interviewer has suspect motives
applicant has a head shaped like a
trapezoid interviewer has turned off
applicants interest in Cornell and they
are going to go to the vastly superior
Dartmouth never heard of it I think I
have every guy have everything I'm
hearing from an or now I will be hearing
the report well that will not be pretty
and you will not be please cancel your
affiliation or a Cornell that is all sir
you may go
[Music]
[Applause]
butternuts ready to get squashed
let's you guys why smoke your butts
because ray ray and the bees don't even
go right
we don't do or what let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
I graduated from anger management the
same way I graduated from Cornell on
time now I'm back got a second chance
and I'm not gonna blow it so look out -
under Mifflin
I mean look out in a fun way you know
not like I'm gonna hurt you
hey guys guess who's back no need to
thank Charles Boyle he's a grinder not
the most brilliant detective but he
works harder than anyone else he's not
physically this is parkour internet
sensation of 2004 and it was in one of
the Bond films it's pretty impressive
the goal is to get from point A to point
B as creatively as possible so
technically they are doing parkour as
long as point a is dilution and point B
is okay we all go together or we go one
at a time here it is here it is truck
two refrigerators two dumpster 360 spin
onto the palace
backflip gainer into the trash hardcore
parkour
you